[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and what an absolutely
crazy episode of genv that was it's
easily up there as being my favorite in
the entire series and I'm so hyped to
talk about what happens in it throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
all down going through the Easter eggs
hidden details and our theories for the
finale now we pick up with a student
being thrown into the woods which is
where we realize they've been dropped in
with the contagious soups the kid says
what did I do and it's possible that he
was just grabbed up by shed's goons
without even doing anything wrong in the
past they'd mov kids here from Sage
Grove which is why Sam was present
rather than him being a student this is
because of a student when missing people
might ask questions but here they've
started dipping into their own classes I
feel like the shows they've taken things
to the next level and in order to stop
students asking about the others they've
pulled them all together Andy this is
why this guy recognizes him but let me
know below if you took it another way
either way shed and cordosa watching on
as they die with a former wanting to
make it Airborne there's obviously been
a lot of fears over viruses in the last
couple of years and I think this is
touching upon some of the conspiracy
theories surrounding how some have been
created got to scared around it cuz
YouTube demonetizes channels for talking
about it but I'm sure if I show up at
your house to go over it I'll just get
one of my videos demonetized either way
kosa feels like he's in too deep now cuz
he's having to basically killed the Deep
getting a phone call from Kate Shetty
asks if she's taking a medication and
you could actually catch Kate taking it
earlier in the episodes not doing it
mean she's now off the leash and this is
slowly pushing her towards being a
villain on a TV we get some
foreshadowing for what's to come with
Victoria Newman as we see Cameron
Coleman who pops up later on in the
episode around it we can also catch some
Funko Pops of homelander two Starlights
and a black noir got most of them except
that Starlight one with the original
uniform there which is also boxed up to
the right hand side with the Amazon
exclusive
sticker now there's also a homeand land
a figure and several little Flags which
the character of course uses as a cape
we also hear Coleman say with the
historically unpopular and phony
socialist scammer herself vice
presidential candidate Victoria Newman
Newman is basically an AOC parody and
this is what many of her critics call
her he also mentions George Soros who
donates a lot to the Democratic party as
we know though it doesn't matter either
way because vot and control of both of
these sites they've whipped people up
into a frenzy where they've become so
tribal that they'll stand by their side
no matter what's revealed this loyalty
has created massive followers who do
whatever they can to do things that then
benefit B now around the table we see
that no one really trusts Kate and also
detail we've only recently caught with
Jordan our edit of map pointed out that
Jordan actually has two sides to their
necklace with one being pearls and the
other being a chain left by herself with
none of her friends throughout this
episode we see Kate feeling like she's
truly being abandoned now outside we can
catch some seven inspired posters for a
train homelander Starlight the deep and
what I think is also Crimson countis
from the amount she's been featured in
the show I'm even wondering if the world
knows soldier boy killed her now we also
see a post of her singer in human's
campaign with soup lives matter spray
painted over the top of it this is later
shouted out at the Town Hall and it
becomes something for the soups to Rally
behind now no points for guessing what
that's a reference to and in the episode
we see how it becomes a chant of
rebellion Marie convinces Jordan to
accept katees on her side side and we
see as the pair then end up kissing
they've obviously got a complicated
relationship but amongst all this
they're trying to make it work we need
Kate now I think in the end Marie's
going to regret doing this as she's
unleashed the monster that people always
suspected she was now though they can
break in aed's computer because they
know that no one's going to believe them
however Victoria can provide a way to
expose her and luckily for them she's
speaking at the school with Sam and Emma
the former starts having fun at God youu
and and he also discovers the
scite that was featured in the main boy
show even lights up just like how she
does and though she wants him to lie low
he finally wants to live his life he's
pretty much gone from one cell to the
other and we even see the bars in the
windows have being brought down now he
says the last time I had vought a burger
I was with Luke and we've seen this fast
food chain popping up in the show now
there are some Easter eggs that we've
pointed out before but just in case you
missed them here they are and dresser
has lots of different size clothes on it
and this is due to her shrinking size
depending on how much she's sick there's
also a Starlight Funko on the dresser
and termites crazy love two poster
hanging up on the wall next to it is the
queen ma one which we've said a thousand
times it's based off the Wonder Woman
Solo movie that came from DC now in
shed's office we see Marie and Jordan
going through the files and they learn
what's a pretty big bombshell in a
hidden part of the draw turns out shed's
daughter and husband were on the
Atlantic Flight that homelander may have
caused to crash during season 1 it's
probably the first thing I think of when
I think back to that season and it's
such a cool way to tie the main show in
with this as soon as you start seeing
the reports you start figuring it out
and I genuinely got goosebumps seeing
the pieces fall in place as she opens
the file we see a photo of a man and
details of the rescue crew searching in
the wreckage I did go back and look
through the episode but unfortunately I
couldn't find this guy however there
were two girls that may have tried to
hand to homelander but whether either of
these was shed's child or not we never
get confirmed but it instantly makes
sense why she's developing the virus and
in many ways she's mirring buter AR in
the comic Becca was killed due to a sup
Sation in that which was used as the
basis for the show this then set him on
a path of Vengeance which we'll talk
about more at the end of the video once
we get into it though you'll see how
some of the characters are and they may
skip over him doing it in favor of what
happens with her now much like butcher
working with the government in Vault has
opened up the truth and since then she's
used their resources to mount up a plan
could also then ends up coming in and
peeing in some alcohol which I I
wondered was that a Granny's Peach te
reference over hearing his ramblings
they then discover the infection rates
before we cuted the skyline of New York
City if you look closely you can
actually see they added in seven Tower
and we can catch the cranes at the top
still repairing the damage from season 3
it turns out shedy was meeting with none
other than Grace mallerie making this
feel even closer to the main series
Grace is of course sort of align with
shed's goals as her grandkids were
killed by Lamplighter like Shetty she's
lost two people that she cared about and
Shetty wants to help her carry out her
genocide now mallerie wants her to stop
and warns of that vult will crush her
and everyone that she cares about
Gracie's vengeance is being something
out won't bring her loved ones back but
shedy argues it could save others from
facing the same loss at this point Grace
ends up giving an OD to Billy which
again I believe paints them out as being
on similar rocks a man who works for me
one of your fellow countrymen although I
doubt you travel in the same circles has
the same rage this rage is something
that canum buter and in the end it's
what's going to destroy him makes me
wonder whether he'll pop up at some
point in the finale and he may even be
someone who learns about the virus right
now he's living on borrow time as the
doctors gave him less than two years to
live season 3 ended with him planning
the downfall of Victoria Newman which
the events of the show could end up
leading into it definitely seems like
they're setting her up as a big villain
and if she gets the vice president see
I've no doubt she'll be in the hot seat
soon now with Sam we see as he comes out
of the cupboard and starts exploring the
room on the photos on the wall we can
also catch Emma's sparring opponent from
episode one when she was filming her
fight video there's also a Barbie Jeep
as well with some other small cars on
the Shelf which I'm guessing that she
rides around in man starts going through
the underwear drawer to invading our
privacy a lot there mate um but we can
see that she's got all sizes in there
hearing a bang and rushing outside we
can see that one of the Icemen inspir
soups has created a nice little ice
slide this is by Steve who we met
earlier in the season when Emma returned
to her room after going big on social
media ruus then leads Sam to the town
hall and it kind of shows how naive he
is Sam hasn't had much experience unless
he's able to be easily led into being
part of the super Uprising in the comics
this two was inspired by homelander who
after the events of hero orgasms started
inspiring soups to resist their leaders
it was actually during this Arc that he
caused a plane to crash which somewhat
links in with what happened with Shetty
now on the Cameron Coleman show we see
an interview with polarity polarity is
described as a God-fearing soup that
bleeds red white and blue and thus he's
given a warm welcome the Democratic
Victoria is in but I was actually
expecting Coleman to go a bit easy on
her because in the end she's still
someone that V one in control this might
have been a last minute thing though as
we do learn polarity was originally
supposed to be the moderator Coleman
might also not have any information
about what's going on and he could just
be kept in the dark because the
character is just a puppet anyway as we
see Andre seen how much goes on
now and there's not actually anyone
heroic at bought his dad still wants
what's best for him though and I thought
it was a nice touch to include Andre's
posters up around the display now what's
going to bring them together is what
happens next with polarity and he has a
seizure that causes powers to go on
overdrive this brings the entire set
crashing down and from here we cut to
commercials and see an ad for VA
Pharmaceuticals the early days were of
course doing this before they got in the
superhero business and using their
website link takes you to Sony's
television website and back with Emma we
see she walks through a giant vault door
showcasing the kind of security that
they have at the school also notice
there's a Cod red sign in her room as
soups going ballistic would cause a
shitload of issues rushing out to his
dad we sees Andre has to use his powers
to stop him from imploding the ambulance
this has the sign global Wellness
services on the side which is riffing
off the name and symbol of the global
Wellness Institute this also sort of
looks like the Emily May Foundation from
Spider-Man 2 which I I had to take my
myself away from that to just check out
this episode but it was worth it now in
this world the services are owned by V
showing how they have their hands in
everything such a cool and chaotic scene
and I was genuinely fearing for that
paramedics life as things started flying
about in the back cut to Emma looking
for Sam and she comes across Maverick
and Sloan Sloan is actually a student
who looks like in alpaca and alpaca MAV
dick into that
sake anyway we go to the town hall which
is where we see Victoria getting roasted
by Cameron he brings up both Stormfront
and soldja boy who would have distanced
themselves from even though they caused
it now we hear lots of NDS to the
Superhuman registration act which acted
as a way to bring superpowered people
under the reign of the government this
led to the major Marvel event Civil War
which was too started off by a soup
exploding just like soldja boy Newman
wants to offer a seat at the table for
for the soups and as Coleman mentioned
she's currently not too popular with
them what I think is brilliant about
this is that Victoria herself is of
course a soup but she's hidden it from
almost everyone so that she can
infiltrate the government at the moment
it seems like they're B from doing so
and in the end V has all the power I
wonder if her revealing this will
eventually win around the super
community and then push her and singer
off the edge to become the winners of
the election I kind of doubt it though
cuz then the head exploding thing could
be linked with her but as we learn she's
very similar to Marie now with her and
Jordan we see as they make a distraction
which leads to her dislocating Justine's
jaw who's chilling out with ratg girl
lots of powers on display like eyel
lasers and it leads to the gods then
leaving their posts now at this point
Vicks ask whether homelander will stand
trial for killing someone there's very
much the feeling that sups are superior
and that it's the humans that should bow
down to them homelanders weaponized them
all under one cause which has a similar
Motif to what he does in the comics sort
of like a Sniper Wolf I not keep going
on about it but it's sort of like a
cyberwolf situation where him not being
held properly accountable opens up the
doors for other soups to break the lawn
act how they want the government isn't
treating them fairly at all and Victoria
wants to use them as a way to win
however due to the backlash here I think
they might go in a civil war Direction
and instead offer the majority of humans
the chance to impede their rights they
may fear the soups could replace them
but Vic could spin it that they get the
best of both worlds her standing up here
could show she doesn't fear the soups
which in the eyes of to regular people
would make her look strong as we know
though she could easily explode
everyone's head so it's not much of a
case of her being feeless she's just
more powerful than they are now we get
some further nods to the X-Men here with
a girl's eyes flashing purple like
psylock and also one screaming similar
to banshe taken off stage Vic recognizes
Marie and we learn that she's in fact a
benefactor both went to Red River and
both have the same powers and she's
willing to tell Marie who she really is
as she seems friendly in says that she
gave her a little boost but I think she
may want to use her for nefarious
purposes say something about Vic that
gets put into the spot light and she
becomes the one who suspected is the
head poppet she could shift the blame to
Marie and though the dates don't
necessarily line up due to her being in
Red River I'm sure they could do
something to spread misinformation now
back with Shetty we see his cake
confronts her and she tests whether she
actually loves her for real shedy
genuinely cares and in the end she sees
her as a surrogate daughter now Kate
needs a mother too and shedy Promises to
keep her safe from the virus it seems
legit but Kate's very much an embodiment
of her killing her own mother and
casting her ties to humanity away during
the boys diabolical we saw the students
of Red River breaking out and going out
to enact revenge on their parents I feel
like Hat's killing shett in the same
vein as this too with it being about her
stepping out from the confines of
someone who's controlled her also quick
correction last breakdown a called kada
reality warper but as you guys pointed
out she she she isn't really she's
mainly just a powerful psychic rather
than being someone that can change the
fabric of reality itself now with Newman
we see her and Marie meeting for the
first time and can catch some posters on
the wall along with the dawn of the
seven ons we have a crimson countless
whiskey Sunrise which is a play on the
Tequila Sunrise film this also
translucent invisible force too and I
love the way his head's missing from the
suit And the tagline you can't kill what
you can't see an human also well you can
if you stick a bomb up their ass now
human also makes a joke about her powers
otherwise I think they might take off my
head this is her way more Charming than
we've seen her before and I feel like
she's a different woman after stepping
out from under boort getting Marie to
sense the v in her blood this very much
creates a connection between the pair in
which they're quote unquote blood
sisters Marie's been looking for a real
mentoring connection since episode one
and it seems like Vic may be the one
Marie tells her about the virus but she
seems to just brush it off and tells
Marie to go back to school she says she
could be the first black woman in the
seven which is something Marie's wanted
since episode one I think you meant to
say first black woman in the seven this
is all that she's ever focused on but in
the end Marie seems like she's going to
go against this in order to do the right
thing that's what I really love about
the boys and though it seems like it's
just a party it also has these really
heroic ARS for their characters to go on
now the series has been very focused on
Parental and mental figures due them
being the ones that made their kids take
the V nowhere has his conflict been
stronger than with Andre and his dad who
he catch at his bedside in hospital
judging by the windows I'm guessing this
is the seven Tower which someone of his
stature would be taken to to be looked
after he ends up not going out to shetes
while the rest do and it's going to be
interesting to see if he abandons his DB
for the finale now here we catch Kate
having instructed Shetty to be under her
control this is given to us with a nice
little clue that Kate's eyes are
bloodshot at this point here we see the
that the roles have been reversed and
all the fears everyone had about Kate
have come true she is holding shedy
hostage but she has Fair reason with the
reveal of what's happening at the school
they're not there to study it's there to
study them and shed wants to unleash the
disease and wipe out them all Shetty
won't let the soups continue their path
of destruction and she knows that the
soups are destined to cause misery this
is something that we saw from the off
when hu's girlfriend had a train run on
her probably could have woulded that
better but you know what I'm saying they
always caused pain anyway Shetty wanted
Kate to kill everyone in the woods cover
it up and then unleash the virus Shetty
just wants to forget but it's too far
gone and Kate has her do something gets
the video demonetized now it's so cold
how Kate forces Marina to help and
brings things full circle from the girl
that she saved in the club Marie could
do it but she's continued to align
herself with people who aren't too
interested in actually saving others Sam
says it's just this and he and K are two
soups that I can see teaming up next
time now with Newman we see her
collecting the virus from kadosa with
him being completely unaware that she's
his soup he says he just wants to
compassionately control them which does
sound similar to phrases often used in
genocide man gets his head popped off in
what's an amazing reveal and we close
out at the song Heads Will Roll by the Y
yes this starts with the lyrics off with
your head perfectly playing off what
happens in the scene Newman now has the
only container for the virus and she
could even study this for a way to
immunize herself and wipe the rest out I
do feel like her blood Powers could even
keep her safe as she'd be able to
potentially take it out her system if
Marie can see V within someone's blood
the pair could actually potentially pull
it out of their system either way
there's lots of things to look forward
to next week and I absolutely love this
finale the series has been killing it
and this week was the best one so far
for me just can see all the pieces
falling into place and there's so many
major reveals in it that I wasn't
expecting at all bring Victoria and into
it as well was a big move and it's just
so good watching her Kate and Shetty
what and what happened to them in the
episode now we are going to be getting
into Comic spoilers so check out now if
you don't want to know what could be
happening I have talked about this a
fair few times before so might you might
also just get bored so if you leave I'm
not bothered you son of a either
way homelander ends up Rising with a
majority of the soups and he kills the
president Vic and tries to take control
at this point but is sent in and after
the black and reveal that he's a clone
of homelander he ends up killing him
before butcher takes his life and the
comy keeps going and we see as butcher
kills the rest of the boy Team all
except for Huey his end gamees to set
off a radio frequency that will trigger
V within all the soups and cause them to
die on mass across the entire planet now
that hasn't been set up like it has been
in the comics and instead I think the
virus will be what goes down in the show
I am predicting that Vic gets put in the
presidential seat after she takes that
singer and then but you will take the
the virus from her and unleash it on the
world I know he doesn't have much time
left but I think that's the way that
things are going to end up going shed
was clearly a standing for him and not
only did she lose her family due to the
soups but she also wanted Revenge she
created something that could wipe them
all out which butcher will of course
also want to do as well now in the end
I'm so hyped to see what happens with it
and I think there's lots of ways that
they can end up taking things buter
might even end up taking out himself if
he still has v24 in his system and they
could go that way with Huey trying to
stop his plants lots of things going
down obviously let me know your thoughts
below and huge thank you again for for
sitting until this point please drop a
like on the video and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out you want to
get some heavy spoilers merch we've also
got our t-shirt line located below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time one
house of dragon stuff Marvel T's and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out cuz there will be something you
love now if you want something else to
watch we've got our lowkey breakdown on
screen right now so definitely head over
there right after this out the way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I've been Paul let's see you next time
take care peace